you
all right hello this is Adam Smith hi oh
hi thank you very much indeed for making
time for this must be a very busy day um
I I've read on the news was that you
didn't actually receive a call from
Stockholm this morning I did not well I
I did I didn't answer it because I slept
through it reasonable enough i guess it
was early in the morning well it also
has to do with the fact that the normal
ring on my home phone had been changed
inadvertently a couple days ago and I
never took the time to change it back to
the regular ring so it was actually
quite faint so I when I actually did
finally wake up I actually heard
something ringing and I thought up that
must be somewhere else another apartment
how did you actually find out the user
ah this is a sort of ridiculous
situation but is sort of funny I i woke
up at ten after six and i realized that
they must have given the prize in
chemistry so i simply said okay who's
the schnook that got the price this size
that's what I opened up my laptop and I
got to the nobel prize fight and I found
out I was the schnook it was very funny
that divine not energy guys are really
terrific scientists but I so this is a
very big and very nice surprise lovely
way to hear um if we just turn to the
work for which you're awarded you had
the idea of using green fluorescent
protein in species other than the
jellyfish in which he was found and it
was Doug prasher who cloned it and then
you you had the idea of taking it from
him and expressing it in your systems
and see I would put it slightly I would
use the wording slightly differently I
had heard about gfp and a seminar that I
was listening to in about nineteen
eighty early nineteen eighty Max and I
tried to find out who was studying this
and whether we could work on it and I
talked to Doug and he had ideas that
this would work as well and he was
wondering about it me through that was
certainly the motivation he had in
cloning this dasteen and so we worked we
had very excited about a one hour
conversation on the phone and
the upshot of that was that we were
going to collaborate and see if this
would work in C elegans and through a
couple of Miss outs that took us a
couple of years to actually get back in
touch with one another but in 1992 we
did and we got the clones from Douglas
and a very good graduate student this
gives kirkin put this in e.coli and we
had green fluorescent e.coli within a
month this yes all quite amazing it and
the worm you study is actually
transparent so that you can you can
label cells and then see them in the
living world that's correct so when I
first heard that seminar describing gfp
and realize I work on a transparent
animal this is going to be terrific I'll
be able to see the cells within the
living animal that's what really was the
motivation right right so just one last
question do you have you thought about
how you might celebrate once you get off
the phone with you well they had a nice
reception here already in the department
and we're going to have some friends
over to this evening and i'll try to
wake up tomorrow and say that it wasn't
a dream I think that'll be the
celebration okay best of luck thank you
very much nice talking thank you so much
but I